okay, here's one of those things that really
is a huge deal and I want to tell you how
big of a deal it is, but I don't want to seem
hyper
Bolick, but it actually is a really big deal.
So it's important to communicate how big of
a deal it is.
And I'm talking about the census.
The Trump administration has now missed the
deadline to print the census forms.
Now this is an attack on one of the fundamental
institutions of our country.
Every 10 years there's a census.
We count everyone.
The information is used to make really important
and influential decisions about how funds
are distributed, how congressional districts
are reallocated, really important stuff that
affects our country for a full decade until
the following census.
And you might remember, you know when the
Wright was talking about Obama's not going
to leave the White House in 2016 Obama is
going to declare martial law and suspend the
2016 election.
It is counterproductive.
Bottom feeding, garbage conspiracy crap.
And we were right to ignore it from the left.
When Trump says he's possibly not going to
accept election results, be it 2016 or 2020
or whenever.
Those are really disturbing possible attacks
on our democratic system, but as I've said
before, I can't think of any way in which
Donald Trump would be able to successfully
carry out not leaving the White House if he
loses in 2020 but the census is the census
and it is a huge part of what we do as a country
and we don't have to speculate about what
the Trump administration is doing because
they're doing it right now.
It's not.
They might do it at some point in the future.
I've been telling you for years the 2020 census
is coming up.
When we think about the 2020 election, remember
we're also going to be doing the census in
2020 Republicans got to draw districts in
2010 they know the importance of the 2020
census.
I've been warning you for years now that the
census is underfunded.
For a while there was no census director.
I actually don't even know if there is now
a census director.
And then the Trump administration started
talking about, let's put a citizenship question
in the census.
Clearly met to dissuade even legal immigrants
from participating, which helps Republicans
by undercounting minorities and shifting funds
in ways that are advantageous to Republicans
and they're continuing to do it.
They are now citing this disagreement about
the citizenship questions legality that a
supreme court recently said as as conceived.
You can't include the citizenship question.
The Trump administration says, yes, we can,
and now they have missed their own deadline
of July one the day of the month to get the
paper forms printed for the 2020 census.
And in fact, the forms haven't even been approved
by the White House at this point in time.
Uh, the office of Management and Budget, OMB,
uh, is in charge of this.
Now, if you're thinking critically, and I
hope that you are, you would already realize
it is a huge problem for something as important
as the census forms to be controlled by the
White House at all.
The head of the OMB is Trump's acting chief
of staff.
Mick Mulvaney, Mick Mulvaney gets to decide
if and when the census forms are printed.
In principle, the census is supposed to start
in five months.
It starts in Alaska.
Okay.
And then it moves on to other parts of the
country during 2020 Trump now is looking very
strongly at delaying the census altogether,
which increases the chances that it doesn't
get done on time or at all or fully or properly
or whatever you want to, uh, consider is a
possibility of what will happen here.
So this is a real attack on our own country
and Obama's gonna declare martial law.
There was never any chance of that.
It never happened.
Trump won't accept the 2020 results.
Well, maybe he will try not to.
I believe that if he loses, he will be removed.
This is going on right now.
Okay.
I wouldn't put it past this administration
to just go ahead and print the census forms
with the citizenship question.
No matter what the Supreme Court says, because
this is an administration that has gotten
away with basically everything.
Yeah.
Some people are in prison because of, uh,
things they did in connection to Donald Trump's
campaign and his administration.
But this is one of those things where, uh,
you know, the Constitution doesn't outline
any specific punishment or consequences for
mishandling the census.
Once again, much like Robert Mueller said
in his report, there are other remedies available
to lawmakers, meaning it would be up to our
lawmakers to say, wait a second, a president
delaying a census for political reasons.
That's impeachable in our assessment, more
than likely missing this deadline is not in
competence, although there's plenty of incompetence
to go around.
It's part of the plan and they're getting
away with all of it.
Okay?
Quite simply, if we don't vote this corrupt
family out, all of this continues and on balance,
they're going to get away with it.
Ivanka, right in there at the [inaudible]
20, having no business being there whatsoever,
they're getting away with it.
Violations of the Hatch Act, Kellyanne Conway
ignoring a request to appear before Congress
because of, or violations of the hatchback.
No consequences, uh, obstruction.
I mean, listen, we already talked about obstruction.
Are we actually going to say there aren't
going to be consequences here.
And if I understand Republican elected officials
refuse to hold Donald Trump accountable, then
we've got to hold those Republican elected
officials accountable.
Meaning they must be removed in 2020, whichever
ones are up for reelection, meaning, you know,
members of the house and only one third of
the members of the Senate.
But it's not even clear that Republican voters
are interested in holding them accountable.
So I don't even know how to put a positive
spin on this, but what I can tell you is all
of the hypothetical attacks on the systems
that we believe to be important, uh, foundations
of how the United States works, including
the census.
Uh, the attacks are happening right now.
We don't have to hypothesize, we know what
they're doing.
It's disgusting.
It's vial.
There should be consequences.
I'm not confident there will be lemme know
what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show,
the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com.